hello my name is alan and i'm a
volunteer at the raleigh windmill
and welcome to the third floor by now
you're about two-thirds of the building
and i suspect you're feeling a bit tired
this is the highest we can go although
there is actually a couple more floors
above us
but these have not been restored if you
look out the window opposite
you're looking towards raley mount which
is owned by the national trust
as you may notice you can only see the
bottom part of the sale
and this shows how how high we actually
are and how much further
we need to go up the building to see the
center of the sails
the metal fence below you may notice
the land behind it dips down slightly
and then rises
this is show this is the edge of the
boundary of the national trust property
and shows the remains of the old ditches
that were there when the castle was
built
in the center of the room you can see a
model of rayleigh castle
this is a mott and bailey castle this
type of
fortification was built throughout
england by the normans
as you may remember from school william
the conqueror
invaded this country in 1066
and took over all the land he gave
a large amount of land in south east
essex to
robert fitzweinmark this castle was
probably started
around about 1070 and is shown in the
doomsday book which was
published in 1086
by this time it was held by his son
swain
as you may note this is how come
the local schools fits weimark and swain
have gained their names this model shows
the castle
in about 1180 or thereabouts
and why is it here you may ask well this
is a natural high point for the whole
area
if you look out this window looking
northwards
you can see the edge of hull bridge the
edge of rayleigh and in the distance
south wooden ferrous and the old water
tower at latchington
so clearly you've got a very good view
northwards
if you look out this window over this
side near the door
you can see the tall buildings in south
end
so this is a good illustration of what a
good vantage point
this castle has over the whole area
these modern bailey castles were usually
made of wood as they could be
constructed fairly quickly
with relatively low skilled workers
much later in around about 11 50
stone cladding was being added to the
mound
part of the site to improve the
durability
of the area by the early 1200s
it was no longer required and gradually
fell into disuse
the castle itself may look small to our
eyes
but to the local population it was
massive
they only lived in small thatched
buildings
so this large construction was totally
alien to them
as the castling railing fell into
decline
the local lord began to construct
a newcastle at hadley overlooking the
thames estuary
eventually in 1394
richard ii gave permission for the
townspeople of rayleigh to use the stone
in the site
and it became farmland for the next 500
years
by the early 1900s the site was saved
for future generations by its donation
to the national trust